remember me yeah you do
you're even [ __ ] uglier than I am now
what do they do to you doesn't matter
it's not how it ends for you brother you
know is coming for you you've always
known
hey everybody so I got a lot of requests
for a cleganebowl video amongst other
big things that are gonna be happening
in season 8 or at least implied to be
happening according to the gauntlet that
the Hound just threw at the mountains
feet so there's just a couple hoops that
they have to jump through in order to
pay this off but obviously they wouldn't
have included that in there had they not
intended to do something with it in
season 8 so because we're in the off
season now if you are finding me for the
first time I do Game of Thrones every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'm still doing an HBO
giveaway that I'll explain at the end of
the video too but the Hound himself was
probably one of the MVPs of the season
the mountain didn't do a whole lot even
though he got that makeover along with
the rest of Circe's new Queen's Guard
they you know he does look like the
mountain that he saw in his vision like
there was this thing going on with the
riders this season where they tried to
make reference to as many different
things as possible with the lines of
dialogue that they had the hounds vision
back during the early episodes probably
one of the best scenes that they came up
with themselves like there's still a
little bit of George art Martin that
they're trying to include from the books
but we have gone off book more than 50%
so I will try to address possible
cleganebowl in the books but previously
you probably heard about this theory for
at least the last couple of years
at least right up until season 6 where
they had Tom an outlaw trial by combat
when Sir she was getting ready for her
trial with the faith so originally
cleganebowl started out as sort of a
spinoff from the gravedigger theory
because we didn't know whether the Hound
was coming back or not the last we saw
of him was the end of season 4 Brienne
had left him for dead Aria had left him
for dead but the whole thing is is a
during feast for crows Brian is on her
quest to find and save Sansa which is
sort of what she did at the end of
season 5 beginning of season 6 and as
she's searching for her in the salt pans
she comes upon a place called the quiet
Isle there's a person called the
gravedigger there and she notices that
the hounds horse is nearby so there's
just a lot of clues that pointed towards
the Hound coming back then sure enough
during season 6 we got that ian mcshane
scene where he doesn't quite play a
character from the books but it's their
version of the gravedigger seen in that
area of Westeros so that's how he sort
of runs into the
Brotherhood and makes his way north and
they rope him back into the plot so they
went a little off-book there but the
whole thing is that it sounded like the
Hound had become a more religious person
so we had this trial of the faith coming
up Circe will try to throw in her ace in
the hole the mountain and everyone was
hoping that the faith would surprise us
by bringing the Hound out like oh we
have this person who's now very
religious who might not necessarily be
one of the faith militant but is
somebody who could take on the mountain
the whole idea with the mountain is that
they're presenting him is effectively
invincible especially now that he's
Undead so there's this big theme with
fire on the TV show wildfire blew fire
now from the undead dragon in the
traditional gold red fire from Daenerys
dragons so just remember that but when
the Hound had his vision of the mountain
shaped like an arrowhead and he was
digging those graves that was sort of a
way for them to tie up that gravedigger
plot from the books like oh yes he is a
gravedigger but I was surprised by the
number of people after this particular
scene in the finale when he said you've
always known what's coming for you
brother
and then stomps off I think some people
were confused about whether or not he
was talking about a prophecy or
something that he saw in a vision like
the army of the Dead but really he's
talking about himself he's talking about
cleganebowl so it raises a couple big
questions because the mountain will
never leave Circe's side he's far too
important to her in the Hound is headed
back up north
so there are nowhere near each other so
the question is is like if he's coming
for the mountain then when is that going
to happen how is that going to happen
because if the army of the Dead is gonna
wash over Winterfell eventually then
isn't the Hound one of those tragic
figures who would give his life in this
big redemptive moment if he hasn't
already achieved a measure of redemption
he probably had one of the best arcs of
season seven I would say of all the
people worthy of an MVP award he
probably somewhere near the top but even
if he doesn't embrace the red God in the
way that Barrack or the red priests do
he still believes in the red God like
he's not going to abandon his mission
just to come down to King's Landing to
kill his brother so here's where we get
into season eight theory territory
because you have all these reunions that
are left to have
at Winterfell like you have John in the
stark family but you also have the hound
reunion with Arya but just as big you
have a hound reunion with Sansa I know
there are a lot of people who are
wondering about the saan saan theory I
don't think that's gonna be a huge thing
I'm expecting more of like a Brienne
hound moment where it's really funny and
touching they acknowledge each other and
we can always talk about that more in
another video but I don't expect too
much of post-games Sansa hound stuff to
be happening
Arya probably had the more meaningful
relationship with him on the TV show
just because they spent so much more
time together and they literally invoke
her when they're walking to the dragon
pit to have this big meeting here so
theory that all takes place all those
reunions in the first couple of episodes
they deal with the threat of the night
king in the middle episodes towards the
very end and then by the very end that's
when he circles back around comes back
down to King's Landing and kills his
brother the mountain because the only
other way that you pay off cleganebowl
is if Cersei takes the mountain north
and she sounds like she's not going
anywhere outside of King's Landing
that's her whole thing is that she's the
queen even if she's going to be the
queen of ashes that lanta dialogue from
Davos about being the skeleton that sits
on the throne was probably one of the
most foreshadowing prophetic moments
that the show had during the season
something to keep in mind and also sort
of a reference to Cersei who just
obsessed with the Iron Throne like
Daenerys is slowly backing off of that
because of what happened the last couple
of episodes that she hasn't completely
abandoned her quest to take down Cersei
but Cersei is still 100% keeping control
of the realm and I can't remember the
last time that she left King's Landing
so it would be kind of weird if she
started now so it's not necessarily
confirmation that the Hound is going to
survive the battle with the night king
or whatever their big final battle is
but remember he would have to circle
back around come back down to King's
Landing and that would likely take place
after all that's happened but as they
made such a big deal about fire killing
the undead and Fire is such a big thing
for the Hound it's still one of the few
things that could trigger him his origin
story is so tied up in fire with the
mountain as big part of that in now that
he's the zombie
Mountain and you need fire to kill
zombies it just feels like fire will be
a critical component in the way that the
Hound defeats the mountain although I
would be amazed if there isn't a badass
sword battle it just feels like the
mountain is supposed to be relatively
unkillable by traditional means now like
that's the whole thing the Qyburn did to
him like you could stab him as many
times as you wanted to unless you
chopped his head off and burned him
Qyburn could just bring him right back
so hopefully that explains a little bit
about cleganebowl and Season eight and
how they could pay that off there's
still a number of ways they could choose
to achieve it but just remember that
it's very unlikely that the Hound would
completely abandon the battle against
the night King to come back to King's
Landing just to take care of his brother
so that feels like something that would
happen after so it would also mean this
Cersei is probably around late in the
game too but we can talk more about her
during my Jaime video that I'll do in
the next week or so there's also a
golden company video that I was working
on but I decided to do this first
because it sort of gets tied up in Jon
Snow stuff and I've done a lot of Jon
Snow videos lately but just as a sort of
teaser for that remember what the golden
company did with Aegon in the books and
remember who is now named Aegon on the
TV show so just something to think about
I'll do that video this weekend but
leave all your requests for Season 8
videos or if there's anything else
leftover from season 7 that you guys
want me to do but also just a reminder
that there's other HBO related stuff
that'll be happening early next year so
obviously they go into production for
season 8 in October but there's a really
strong chance that Westworld will drop
in the spring next year so that means
they'll start dropping trailers sometime
later this year so we'll slide into West
world slowly while I'm also doing Game
of Thrones videos so if you have
Westworld requests just leave them in
the comments below too but that next
Game of Thrones video should post by
Saturday at least but congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Rodrigo Garre
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here for my new
season 8 playlist I just made like a
brand new playlist for season 8 specific
stuff and you can click here for all my
season 7 videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight